go viral for that basically changed  everything oh he put out a video called  professor against political correctness  and it was literally because he was  coming downstairs in the kitchen  complaining about hr in universities and  my mom was like just put it on youtube  it went viral there were protests he was  on the cover of newspapers podcast  invites and this was 2016's and so i was  helping my mom because my dad asked her  for help for scheduling things because  my mom was completely overwhelmed and my  dad was really stressed out he thought  he was going to lose his job at  university and at that point he had been  a tenured professor yes and it was at  risk